- The best suggestion
I've had in the last year?
The daily routine of an Aztec high priest.
That was the best suggestion.
So, we'll come to this side first.
Thank you for putting the lights on
so I can hold people accountable.
If the lights are down,
usually some idiot guy
at the back is like,
"Oh, it's my time to just
shout sex and crude things,"
but now the lights are on,
you feel more self-conscious.
So, guys over here, what do
you want to hear a rap about?
- [Off Camera] Sex in space!
- See, I just said that
guys shouting sex--
Just because you add in space
to it doesn't make it...
I mean, admittedly, it
is a great suggestion.
Sex in space-- are you involved with NASA?
No, no, would you like to be?
Purely for that.
Just like, "Yeah, maybe I'll..."
I don't know, anyway sex in space.
I apologize but that is
the first suggestion.
Anyone put a hand up over here?
The kids that didn't
make it in Willy Wonka.
That is an absolutely
fantastic suggestion!
You knew that, as well.
You were like, "I'll just put my hand up
"'cause it's a real good one."
(audience laughs)
Wow, the kids that didn't
make it in Willy Wonka
and sex in space.
Let's come to people at
the back of the room.
Let's get you guys.
Yeah, hand up there.
Where's Waldo?
It's kind of a boring suggestion.
I hate to be-- Fine, I'll take it.
I thought you were gonna be with me, like,
"Yeah, it does suck."
But no, you were all like,
"Oh, we kinda wanted that."
Sex in space, the kids that
didn't make it in Willy Wonka,
Where's Waldo.
There's a hand up here, yeah.
TSA reform!
(audience laughs)
In favor of making it more
stringent or more lax?
There's definitely a 50-50 split.
What's your views on TSA,
how should we reform it?
It's up to me?
I asked you the question.
I don't want to silence
you; I'm interested.
If you could change one thing about TSA,
what would it be?
No TSA?
All right, Osama, what's wrong with you?
(audience laughs)
Okay.
So, sex in space, the
kids that didn't make it
in Willy Wonka, Where's
Waldo?, TSA reform.
This side of the room.
You've only really got
one suggestion to give
'cause they all stole all of yours.
Let's see if we can
crowd-source a really good one.
We'll get a few and then pick the best.
- Pruno!
- Pruno?
Is that prune juice?
It's what?
Jail wine, it is!
And you make it by--
You put, like, anything that
kind of ferments with sugar
in a sock in the back of
a toilet cistern, right?
Well, like, no!
Don't make it out like I've been inside.
I've not done hard time.
Not with a face like this, gosh.
Pruno.
I mean, that is a better suggestion
than anyone here is gonna give.
Okay.
Pruno, prison sex,
Where's Waldo, TSA reform,
and the kids that didn't make it in--
Oh no, sorry, not prison sex.
I've got that on the brain now.
(audience laughs)
You're just making me think about it.
Sex in space.
It's because a week ago,
someone suggested prison sex,
so that's why I'm thinking about that now.
I'm just wondering, yeah, that's cool.
Okay, cool.
Right, now I've got my
Freudian slip out of the way.
This then, lovely people in
the Comedy and Magic Club.
To close out the show, a fun little thing
called a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on--
You say, "Whoa!" like,
clearly that's what was
being set up, right?
(audience laughs)
I wasn't gonna go,
"Okay, you're suggestions
are these five things,
"good night and goodbye!"
(audience laughs)
No, I'm gonna turn them
into a beautiful song.
It's gonna be amazing.
It's not prepared, it's not scripted.
Don't worry, it won't
be anywhere near as bad
as you're expecting it to be.
You seem so unconvinced.
That's okay, let's drop
that beat, good sir.
(hip hop music)
It's a good one, as well.
It's got a nice little
kind of afro-beat-style.
♪ Never done hard time but I know ♪
♪ In a jail cell you
can always find pruno ♪
♪ Not nice like it's from Bordeaux ♪
♪ Made down the back of a toilet bowl ♪
♪ I just pop off the
lid, I can't resist 'em ♪
♪ I drink it straight out
of the sock in the cistern ♪
♪ It's a problem in our prison system ♪
♪ I wanna get drunk but
the guards resist 'em ♪
♪ No, don't give the criminals booze ♪
♪ So they gotta make pruno in their loos ♪
♪ Put in the toilet, put it in the cell ♪
♪ Annoyingly the horrible
spoils it that smell ♪
♪ Makes it ferment so wrong ♪
♪ Why is the prison
sock stretched so long ♪
♪ Probably 'cause they
take their time to ♪
♪ Ferment any sugar-containing
thing to wine ♪
♪ It's how you make alcohol content ♪
♪ If I met a guy ♪
♪ In a continent called Britain ♪
♪ Well technically Europe ♪
♪ And I liked chocolate ♪
♪ Well I adore it ♪
♪ You could see me, I'm Charlie Bucket ♪
♪ I get a little gold ticket ♪
♪ Oh I'm in luck ♪
♪ It's an invitation to the factory ♪
♪ I think I'm gonna win ♪
♪ What are my chances ♪
♪ Be maybe one out of six ♪
♪ Because Augustus Gloop he can't resist ♪
♪ He just licks his lips ♪
♪ Oh yes y'all ♪
♪ When he sees a chocolate waterfall ♪
♪ Even though Willy Wonka
doesn't invite him ♪
♪ He just says I'm gonna go and dive in ♪
♪ He's a real portly dude ♪
♪ A fat German kid
getting stuck in a tube ♪
♪ Next one it was her own fault ♪
♪ Horrible girl, Veruca Salt ♪
♪ She was like oh yeah, this isn't hard ♪
♪ And what about Violet Beauregarde ♪
♪ She chewed that gum
'till she got so big ♪
♪ Grew 'till she's blue ♪
♪ What a fat pig ♪
♪ And then you had
another guy we can agree ♪
♪ American character Mike Teevee ♪
♪ He liked violence, he liked guns ♪
♪ He didn't get the factory ♪
♪ 'Cause it wasn't that fun ♪
♪ There probably was another
one that I am forgetting ♪
♪ It doesn't matter ♪
♪ Charlie Bucket's parents
always stayed in the bed ♪
♪ Grandparents, Grandpa Joe ♪
♪ Then the great gas elevator blows ♪
♪ Right through the roof and into space ♪
♪ What would they do there ♪
♪ Come in his face ♪
♪ Probably ♪
♪ Never show respect to me ♪
♪ Because I'm up in
space and I'm sexually ♪
♪ Admiring the other astronauts ♪
♪ I drive down on the
graph, that's an astroport ♪
♪ I'd go oh yeah ♪
♪ I really wanna tap you ♪
♪ I'd get down kicking Avril NASA ♪
♪ Hey have you got Viagra ♪
♪ Houston we've got a problem ♪
♪ Bring it up here ♪
♪ Tried to do a very
funny pun about that ♪
♪ But it didn't work yeah ♪
♪ On the helmet it goes splat ♪
♪ Gotta make sure that the visor's up ♪
♪ Let me talk about this,
gotta gather it up ♪
♪ All your things hundred mil ♪
♪ In a tiny little bag ♪
♪ TSA guy acting all bad ♪
♪ Oh yeah, we're gonna go and spill ♪
♪ 'Cause this is actually
one oh three mils ♪
♪ That's too many, you gotta get smaller ♪
♪ 3.5 ounces, what a baller ♪
♪ This is out of order ♪
♪ Yeah I will warn all TSA agents ♪
♪ We're starting reform ♪
♪ The lady over there
she should be relaxed ♪
♪ Everybody like we don't pay our tax ♪
♪ For you to make a holiday much worse ♪
♪ Calm down, it doesn't
matter who's first ♪
♪ Or business ♪
♪ Or economy ♪
♪ We don't wanna get
bombed on our holiday ♪
♪ So technically security
is a good thing ♪
♪ If on the plane a bomb could be bring ♪
♪ Or brung ♪
♪ That's the past tense of the word ♪
♪ You'd be looking round
there, you woulda heard ♪
♪ We can search through the bag ♪
♪ If it's deep or shallow ♪
♪ Oh I found it like Where's Waldo? ♪
♪ I technically said Waldo not Waldo ♪
♪ In the UK we have a ball though ♪
♪ We say Wally not Waldo ♪
♪ That's a little fact
that now you all know ♪
♪ Open up the page ♪
♪ What are we like ♪
♪ He's always hiding ♪
♪ With the red and white stripes ♪
♪ Try and hunt him down,
try and have a look ♪
♪ What a gosh darn boring book ♪
♪ Every page is exactly the same ♪
♪ I can't find him ♪
♪ Well who's to blame ♪
♪ You guys are bad,
you're the worst of all ♪
♪ No you're the illustrator ♪
♪ You just drew him small ♪
♪ You hid him away ♪
♪ What a bad job ♪
♪ The yellow and black
striped guy and the dog ♪
♪ Always see him again and again ♪
♪ The tail of the dog
looking like a candy cane ♪
Now there's one more thing
that's slipped out of my brain.
What was the last
suggestion we needed to do?
Was there none left?
Did we do them all?
Gimme one more 'cause
that felt I went too fast.
What? Hardcore PC gaming.
♪ Okay it's all right we improved there ♪
♪ Wearing a SpaceX hoodie, what a loser ♪
♪ You wanna go up there and fornicate ♪
♪ Space sex buddies be
each other's mates ♪
♪ But when you're up there ♪
♪ Watch where you're aiming ♪
♪ This guy he loves hardcore gaming ♪
♪ He's like yo I never come last ♪
♪ I go on Twitch and I play Starcraft ♪
♪ Like all the kids
that are over in Korea ♪
♪ No one even knows about that here ♪
♪ You go and see L.O.L. ♪
♪ League of Legends I can tell ♪
♪ Watch Overwatch with
all the great teams ♪
♪ Playing there on a
massive plasma screen ♪
♪ You play so much but
it's hard to think ♪
♪ You dehydrate when you
play, you don't drink ♪
What a bunch of losers, there you go.
(audience cheers)